[Applaudissements]
tout comme itunes et imberbe et régulier
hanaoui dollars d'armes pour ceux qui
nous regardent two way to welcome to
work
bon ça va mal j'adore mais c'est quoi
cette nouvelle coiffure cc du châtain
cendres et de la lave et moniales la
date à dire on a envie de venir à nous
[Rires]
je suis fou de talent on discute sur
what's déjà les magics discute avec
talent balle et elle m'a envoyé hier
pire vous m'avez envoyé un message très
tard sur what's up d'ailleurs ah ouais
vous sachiez que moi quand il ya crime
on ferme les écoutilles
mais tu me vouvoie ouais c'est vrai je
vous dire à quelle heure vous m'avez
envoyé un message sur wat s'appuyer
voilà je vous le dis non mais ce que je
fais chier l'horaire et ouais minuit
pile
oh là là et votre talent vous écris à
minuit sur le what's up
non mais ça rien à voir ça et vous vous
dites quoi
avec talent on peut pas tout vous dire
le dernier texto que j'ai envoyée c'est
on va le faire
non parce que je vais demander si je
pouvais jouer à la guitare dans son
émission voilà il m'a dit on va le faire
bien sûr qu'on va le faire
est ce que j'ai déjà refusé quelque
chose un invité voilà jamais talhouët
étalons à faire une nouvelle séquence
des instantanés les comme une folle sur
cette séquence parce que on aura une des
plus grandes fans de talent je vous le
dis on va poser des questions sur talent
on va voir qui se connaît mieux talent
elle même ou sa fan
d'accord vous allez voir c'est fois sa
femme analphabète mais je suis grave
onglet je suis en train de mettre en
train de m'expliquer les entraînements
des traitements déchets sont pakistan
c'est comme san francisco mais selon
pakistan on va regarder un extrait dans
un instant de how i wake bien sûr on a
même préparé un medley des plus gros
cartons voilà s'étalent avec tout ce que
ça comporte
merci talent en tout cas d'être là les
chéris